témoignage aucun comptage n'a été
effectué aujourd'hui pour mesurer
l'impact psychologique de cet attentat
sur l'affluence dans le métro parisien
il faut savoir que la ratp transporte
quotidiennement 9 millions de personnes
reportage valérie astruc franck brice et
24 heures après l'attentât
l'hommage des parisiens aux victimes
un hommage bien discrète devant
l'affluence quotidienne quand il ya des
morts forcément des chances émules
à moins d'être complètement advance de
pensable on oblige et nous oblige à
penser à ces genres et surtout si ça
peut recommencer
la crainte d'un nouvel attentat c'est ce
qui pousse aussi la ratp à prendre au
sérieux toute alerte à la bombe
16 heures la station châtelet et évacuer
un peu plus tard c'est au tour de saint
michel la désorganisation est totale et
la nervosité des passagers montent d'un
cran
pourtant le stress ce matin et est
absent des visages la ligne b du rer
vient d'être remise en route
les banlieusards peuvent influer à paris
comme d'habitude je prends les
transports en commun
c'est vrai qu'on a un petit peu plus
anxieux c'est surtout quand on
surveillera tout à l'heure parce que le
matin ça qu'un nul et soja sont encore
en train de dormir mais je pense aux
gens aussi qui vont rentrer tout à
l'heure exprimeront compression poissy
et ce soir le stress s'est ajoutée à l'
angoisse pour la foule des banlieusards
un an demain d'attentats
non